okay good morning everyone welcome to
the recitation section of 10 to 13 this
is our agenda today so first of all we
will review the concept of the physical
state of the substance and secondly
we're going to talk about phase diagram
first of all the physical state is a
state that molecule and exists in
reality so think what many as an example
one can exist as gas liquid and solid
correct so fixed diagram is a tool for
engineer a scientist to interpret or
very easily identify the physical state
at a certain temperature and pressure so
we have these diagram and on the
horizontal axis its temperature with the
unit of Stauskas and on the vertical
axis we have pressure with the unit okay
as we just talked about we have three
different states of water exist in this
diagram at high temperature this is the
high temperature space low pressure
water who exists as correct so this is
the gas day and at low temperature high
pressure but who exists as solid great
and at moderate temperature and pressure
whatever the exist is liquid that's what
we usually see in reality and there are
a lot of there there are some sorry some
of the some of some of the components in
this space diagram you have to identify
the physical state of the matter and
also when they transform from one state
to another so we have three different
lines here so each line represents a
certain condition that a that two phases
can coexist
so for example at 100 Celsius what
Hector Celsius and 101.325 give a
passport so at this specific pressure
and temperature what can exist as gas
and liquid simultaneously so far so
clear okay and here's an intersecting
point of these three lines these
intersecting line is called a triple
point
and this triple point we have three
phases coexist so liquid solid liquid
and gas can exist at this specific
pressure and temperature okay so now
your suggestion supposedly you're on the
mountain of human lighting and that you
know the pressure is slightly lower than
one atmosphere which is less than one
point one kilo Pascal my question is is
the water going to boil at 100 Celsius
or it's going to boil below or above 100
Celsius a 1 there or in here yes it's
Melissa
okay why because if you're a lower
pressure you will intersect that
coexistence
the low-temperature trip excellent does
anyone follow her okay okay so let me
just wrap up today's lesson we first
review the physical state of water
what mechanics is s liquid solid and gas
depending on the temperature and
pressure and then we draw the phase
diagram of water and there are three
different elements there if you remember
first in each space you have the face of
water and then we have the coexisting
lines which is the lines that water can
exist in as two different places
simultaneously and then we have the
triple point where three different
places can places okay any questions for
today okay so this is for today next
time you talk about phase diagram of a
mixture for example if you add sodium
chloride which is salt in water how does
the phase diagram of water change if you
want to know that definitely come to our
next recitation section thank you
you